egli mi che ci sono delle pile da
qualche parte
no non sono per niente inquietato dal
tizio che sta tipo nell'angolino e da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a mi sono
video sono fa vj siamo su che i sani ma
talora ragazzi sembra una figata
pazzesca quindi è un po che non facevo
horror non dimenticare di indossare le
cuffie non ti preoccupare zio che
indosso anche quando cago vabbè comunque
ovviamente un cristiano s'addormenta
sulla scrivania fino a mezzano è ovvio
in teoria e come phinet e freddi spero
ti puoi muovere stavolta questo modo
giusto
ma cos'è ok io vedo le telecamere
attraverso il tablet ma vabè geniale ma
come cazzo fa a parlare così
tranquillamente questa roba che sta
succedendo si spengono le luci come 2 e
vabbè mi chiamo è cheyenne si addormenta
in ufficio si spengono le luci come
niente eppure vi parla tranquillo come
se non fosse successo niente stato si è
chiusa la porta rispetto agli altri ora
non è partito male molto male ti
spiegherà come cazzo hai fatto ad
addormentarti in ufficio fino alla
mezzanotte zio proprio perché un altro
disco a singh ha la barca va
rafa vige il finché la barca va siano
tutti gay si sta muovendo qualcosa la
anonima sedia però dall aida
state calmi ancora non ho fatto niente
state tutti calmi per l'amor di dio mano
si entra con se c'è una sedia non è una
canzone in sè di basso salvami la vita
ti prego iddio
no perché nell'altro phinet air france
ma l'ha salvato la vita non so come
salve ma io io posso non lo tocchiamo è
devo andare sulla scrivania perché ci
sono delle cose che mi servono per un
secondo rischiato di morire di infarto
no è no senti 82 59 perfetto e la
batteria si è scaricata posso prendere
le cose che ci sono qua dato che cazzo
di ufficio e me lo spiegate ragazzi ci
sono le sbarre sentiti allora 825 case
un 9 e stato un piacere fratello e devo
trovare le batterie brill per l'ipad se
no non riesco a giocare a clash royal
mentre sono in ufficio del di qua no
la porta è chiusa con una tessera di
sicurezza non è che si alza qualcosa ma
poi che cazzo ci fa in un ufficio un
animatronic permesso sono fatti devo
trovare degli dei codici oddio pile e
pile e pile e pile dimmi che ci sono
delle pile da qualche parte ma lei da
[ __ ] ma [ __ ] te le cuffie per un
attimo ho creduto di fare una cosa [ __ ]
per un attimo prima era un sogno
buone anche tu la white ancora era un
sogno ma ma le luci si spengono mai la
sinistra anzi sono proprio sicuro che
fosse un sogno cos'è ma x che è peggio
di me sto tizio va bene e usciamo che
magari è meglio non ho capito se era un
sogno meno ma so dove andare per
accendere le luci quindi perfetto perché
c'è l'immagine di un omicidio santo
iddio magari cosa allegra dimmi che sta
ancora lì a terra vi prego lo preferisco
morto si ha ringraziato gesù cristo
salve e non è che ci hai ancora il
codice 9 arm cambiato 970 e l'ultimo non
si capisce va beh nel dubbio che mi si
spenga la luce mi levo dal chiasso
perfetto allora questa 907 fissano archi
cagato addosso perché pensavo che mimì
stessa aggredendo tizio prova beh mi fai
vedere cosa c'è di qua che non ho ancora
visto prima di entrare a morire
c'è l'uscita ma sei scemo cos'è che ti
tiene lontano dalla porta a vetri questa
roba
sei veramente un rincoglionito cioè dei
problemi da quando sei piccolo perché lì
c'è batman quanti problemi questo non
voglio sapere da dove provengono siro
mori va bene o calmo è vi prego fatto
che non succeda nulla
né ogni detto hoeness ha capito che
gioco di merda basta non ne posso più
possiamo uscire per favore ma dietro all
ipad con si vede dal mio ufficio quello
all share è si sporca merda senti la
luce [ __ ] o mi spiegate dove devo
andare vi prego perché adesso so che il
tizio si è alzato perchè io lo so già
perché io le devo sapere le cose
sospira il telefono quello merda lo
sapevo lei possino pià schiaffi in
faccia forte la sorella poiché sono
pienamente convinto
[ __ ] ora il legno si è aperta una
porta a causa va bene cazzo son finito
nei bagni per caso solo dei bagni vabbè
vabbè sta arrivando
che a [ __ ] l'anima trani sta mangiato
prova a nasconderti me ma come ha fatto
a vedermi al vento tutto ma da quanto è
figo
c'è chi con paio di palle pro e allora
se ci siamo di nuovo devo correre veloce
giudico effetto ci sarà un armadio
perfetto meraviglioso va bene vediamo di
non far pagare un po come quando io mi
nascondevo prima delle interrogazioni
puoi smettere di respirare per un
secondo per l'amor di dio che bel
ragazzone quest'ansia neanche un
giocando ad out la strega eccolo eccolo
è andato è uscito perfetto
dove
il mio gatto andato non possiamo uscire
da stupisco della micia la porta lì dice
laporta deficiente ma guarda c'è l'auto
della polizia vedergli ssss o esse non
lo so fare il morso fai un po più di
casino magari grazie quanto prende per
il culo sto gioco horror
l'ho visto ho visto veramente bye bye
bye bye bye bye veloce veloce perfetto
dove devo dove dove vado spiegami cosa
devo fare per uscire da mini indizio
qualcosa devo chiedere su facebook
chiedo su facebook a sotto la scrivania
che aeva perfetto ok infatti capire cosa
devo fare vi prego io posso vedere
agiati deficiente e quindi posso
guardare attraverso l'eco bellissimo e
dov'è quel figo
salve ecco va bene allora posso uscire e
sicuro credo nicchia come non so neanche
guardare un tablet coma pio nel culo a
meno che non mi guardi dentro l'odio un
gioco di merda perfetto
oh merda merda non c'è una luce quadra
spegnere no eh va beh lì vicino
melo su chi vai veloce [ __ ] e chiusa
lo sapevo come minimo sporca la trottola
da venere velocissimo deficiente non ci
voglio credere
non ci voglio credere succhia vabbè
vabbè [ __ ] da ferite
dall'altra parte il tifo non so dove sia
ma meglio così guarda ma quindi posso
andare anche di qua c'è roba promesso
buongiorno archivio guarda mi interessa
solo la portata e la madonna la micro
stavano tenendo qua rinchiuso per poi
tipo liberarlo per usarlo come arma
contro gli haters che cos'è fermi c'è un
qualcomm ce n'è un altro nella scatola
devo credere questo non lo so dai
ragazzi vi prego iddio non l'avete mai
le palle
mau mau motherfucker mao mao figlio di
[ __ ]
ci sarà una star con un qualcosa che
devo fare proprio materialmente oddio
che si scortato un gatto stavo
scherzando scorsa chi vuoi
guarda che ti pare era facile eh vabbè
allora non solo l'uscita fa non si
capisce cosa devo fare non so provato
jia ovunque prefiggo un po meno gli
spaventi però per l'amor di dio vabbè
lasciamo perdere ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto una roba decente servi dove
piaciuto considera un certo argomento è
un mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
e come nel mito totale descrizioni già
certi di skater i civili diavolo
conseguito da ragazzi